[Music]
the white house says it will spend more
than
4 billion to fight covet 19 in native
american communities including
600 million for vaccinations this
morning first lady jill biden
is visiting the navajo nation the
largest native american reservation had
one of the country's highest per capita
death rates
last year more than 1200 of its people
have died of covet
now the territory is leading the nation
in vaccination rates and could be the
first in the u.s
to achieve herd immunity maria
villarreal
traveled to navajo nation in arizona and
new mexico
to check on the fight and the lessons
learned
the journey to reach herd immunity on
the navajo nation hasn't always been a
smooth one
we are going to a small community south
of shiprock new mexico
we're going to get smiles when we get
there nurse lyle lee drove nearly an
hour they give 72 year old jonah johnson
the first
dose there you go right there okay just
let it hang down
good job johnson was willing to take the
vaccine but refused to leave his rural
home
it's very important for us to do these
types of visits
you know and just respecting their
choice mckinley county new mexico
borders the navajo nation and is made up
of more than 70 percent native americans
in september of 2020 this county ranked
first in the state and sixth nationally
for cova deaths per capita at first
we didn't really have our guard up but
once it
hit within our family that's when
reality hit
reality struck quickly for jamie
barbone's family
her mother yvonne tolth got coven 19
first
one of my son he passed he spent like
a month and a half in the hospital
and he fought it but
didn't come home how hard was that for
you yvonne
i would get mad
and just cried a lot and my daughter
just
stood by me and my other kids
the high death toll led tribe officials
to spread the word about the importance
of vaccines
it spread like wildfire navajo nation
president jonathan nez was one of the
first to get his shot posting the
pictures
on social media he also hosts weekly
town halls to help educate nearly
300 000 members any outside entity i
think
of all people of color there's some
distrust with the federal government
and so i think when we started the
discussions
about getting the vaccines we were out
there daily almost
getting the information to our navajo
citizens but it wasn't just
providing that information the moment
they got access to vaccines
leaders split their efforts between mass
vaccination sites like this one
and meeting people out in their own
communities we had a rough time
in kovid but we fought very hard and we
have succeeded
to fight back kovid the tribe's chief
medical officer dr loretta christensen
says their efforts have led to more than
70 percent of navajo nation
receiving their first dose i think that
we are
either at herd immunity or very very
close are you smiling under your mouth i
am smiling yes
i am very proud of what we've done most
of jamie barbone's family has been
vaccinated
with the hope of preventing future
heartache why are you so set on taking
this
what my mom has went through and what
i've seen
i don't want to go through that it's all
about safety and family
that's why i feel 100 percent confident
and happy and safe that the vaccine is
here
even as the navajo nation reaches hurt
immunity they are not letting their
guard down
especially as states around them
continue to open up they are very
worried
about another potential surge so they
have put strict health guidelines in
place
that include a mask mandate and also an
overnight curfew
medeval cbs news window rock arizona
really good to hear because they were
hit so hard so early
and i guess they really you know decided
you know we've got to rely on ourselves
because they're
so isolated very impressive what they've
done and president nez who i've
interviewed a couple of times on cbsn
is exactly that impressive impressive